i watched that video of uh what was it
it's probably it was probably on your
guys recommended it as well of like how
do kidneys
i was gonna watch that i i had it on the
watch later i never did yeah because
a super interesting video i recommend it
but it's like explain it to me
basically it's this guy who uh he got
big off tick tock i think because he's
like uh
he's like works in forensics or
something but basically he
uses like the bodies that you know you
donate to science and
to study things about the human body
basically yeah and uh and this guy got
really big on tick tock i've got his
name
basically just doing short videos of
like did you know that this is this is a
real stomach i'm going to open it up and
show you
how food is digested or whatever and he
has a youtube channel
and he literally gets like a real human
body that likes
yeah he works in like some kind of like
scientific research
dexter or something like that he's one i
dug up earlier
it's like the modern day dexter it's
nice he's not a forensics expert he's
just a tick-tock
has anyone has anyone checked the
scottish credential is he legit
that's just insane i'm sure if i turn up
with a body being like no no i got like
a donation yeah it
donation but like basically like he he
gets like a
a proper human body and like opens up
the kidneys and like explains how kidney
stones form and why they [ __ ] hurt
and stuff and it's like
man i can't imagine something that big
traveling through my dick
that how big is it some of these are big
some of these can go like that but you
have to just hope they break down in
your kidneys like because they just
can't go through the tubes right
these ultrasound uh uh ultrasonic
ultrasonic yeah yeah and you're like
she kid needs to break it they literally
they literally scream at it to like
crumble
essentially screaming he's like and
they're
shattered that's literally what they do
it's actually the title one audio they
play
but in worst case scenarios where like
not even that works that it's so
crystallized and so hard they literally
go through your penis with like a pair
of tweezers to just pull it out
oh i did not need to hear this oh yeah
i'm sorry i don't
need i'm sorry yeah this guy the ins
institute of human anatomy that's the
guy
yeah really cool tick tock channel sound
sounds like a youtube channel
just hope he's not a serial killer yeah
yeah i mean he sounds nice i don't want
any tweezers going on my peepee
yeah i i can't i i literally can't
handle like hospitals at all i just like
faint immediately
that's that's why i'm like really
nervous to get older because you have to
do
you know when you hit like a certain age
you have to do that yeah annual
colonoscopy and she'll like that
it's like i'm just not looking forward
to the day where a camera has to go up
my ass like
hospitals are probably the only fear
that i have that i i think is like
irrational i guess is i guess is that
what it counts as well because lots of
bad stuff happened in hospitals right
it's just like i know the shit's gonna
happen in my body i'm not used to it i
don't like it i don't like anything and
i just i always like get so light headed
to my phone
it's horrible you're scared of needles
or anything like that no i don't give a
[ __ ] about needles it's like operations
and stuff terrify me
yeah just it's just things entering my
body that shouldn't be there yeah even
like when i went to
the dentist the other day like just
having like the [ __ ] [ __ ] in my mouth
like
yeah [ __ ] loud as [ __ ] yeah yeah i
was getting lightheaded i was like [ __ ]
i mean that's why everyone hates going
to the dentist cause like you hear
sounds
in your mouth that just shouldn't be
made anywhere near it's weird because i
didn't give a [ __ ] as a kid i really
i didn't care at all when i had to go
and do that stuff but i don't know what
happened
between like after age 18 where i
suddenly started being terrified of it
i'm not really sure why
like i can barely give myself eye drops
let alone something going into my body
you have that friend who's had like 10
surgeries
yeah right i'm like how the [ __ ] are you
doing this how are you not like [ __ ]
freaking out
yeah right i don't know it's like when
my dad comes back from his annual
colonoscopy
right he's just like you know it's it's
it's it's the same thing it's like yeah
i just went to the park
legit would faint yeah right how do i
tell the doctor like listen i'm a little
[ __ ] bro
i don't know what's gonna happen like
yeah like i'm gonna loop me up or
something i don't know yeah
yeah like i'm lucky enough to like have
never needed to have surgery or anything
like that but just like
the concept of it [ __ ] terrifies me
that that's that's one that's one thing
that [ __ ] even if it's not
life-threatening surgery you know it's
like like the the whole idea of being
under anesthesia just like terrifies me
oh no
i hate the surgeries where you're not on
it yeah or you're on light one like the
surgeries when
like uh i think my parents my mom had
something with a heart and she had to be
awake for it and that sounded terrifying
what yeah because apparently i don't
know it sounded awful like yeah
apparently you can feel it and stuff
yeah it's terrible imagine like you can
yeah yeah exactly right horrible
but if you have to have it you have to
have it right but i think i think
maybe it came from uh i had to get so i
had hemophilia where i'd like
if i bleed i you know don't stop
bleeding i'd go like every
three or six months to the hospital yeah
to go and do tests just to make sure it
wasn't getting worse or getting any
better luckily it didn't get any worse
uh but uh yeah it was awful i hate it
going and i don't it was just like a
terrible experience because
i think it's because of what like the
atmosphere in a whole oh yeah dude yeah
yeah
hospital atmosphere so the ward that i'd
always have to go to which is filled
with like
old people that were like dying yeah and
like some of them couldn't like even
like
think or talk and it was and i felt so
bad because they would talk to me and
they just didn't understand they scared
the [ __ ] out of me when i was like 13.
oh yeah yeah i was like oh my god
oh jesus yeah because it's like it's
it's that like glimpse into a possible
future
oh [ __ ] i could be like that one day
yeah and the smell
yeah yeah they're talking about smells
hospitals do definitely have a
distinction
even like thinking about the smell makes
you uncomfortable that's what i hate
about the dentist as well like the
dentist has that like type of smell
that's like
oh what is that i don't know that's why
when you get it
then dentists smell sanitized i don't
know so
when you like it's like it's overly
sanitized you know where it's like this
is too
yeah it's like you just stepped into a
crime scene yeah just like oh man
but like it's everything's bleached yeah
everything's bleached to [ __ ] i hate it
when the doctor like doesn't talk at all
doesn't like crack jokes or anything
i like it because like when the nurse
when the nurse is like funny as [ __ ] i
feel so good i feel like
i'm chill yeah nurse is like cracking
jokes she's like yeah i do this all the
[ __ ] time
and like and she's like tell me about
funny old other
patients and stuff i feel so more at
ease when the doctor doesn't say
anything i'm like what's going on talk
to me what's going on yeah where the
doctor doesn't smile or anything like
that yeah i'm like whoa what's going on
bro yeah come on tell me
i know you're being serious with your
job but you know help me calm down a
little bit dude it's like
[ __ ] hell it's like we're at a job
interview